the Joe Rogan experience yeah I wonder I
wonder who as has won the culture war
there's certainly a battle that's been
won in terms of like control of social
media control social media is absolutely
laughable this is unfortunate for
conservatives but technology is a force
that also pushes left so if you look all
throughout human history like the left
essentially grows and grows and grows
right why is that why is it inexorably
that as some commentators have said
Leviathan slouches left the maya 'then
is the government why does it slash left
and I think a lot of that has been
because of technology technology has
made it so that it makes more like
Industrial Revolution technology we all
band together we're Ward's of the state
right contraception is a technology that
it kind of helps lean leftward it takes
away from the family unit abortion is a
technology right it was impossible
thousands of years ago so technology
actually empowers the individual the
individual means that you have the
breakdown of family structure and
religion and all that and I'm not
missing it at that but it does mean that
there's a leftward shift to it now we're
getting a small set of technologies that
actually can take you more rightward
encryption as an example because
encryption makes it easier to have
privacy it makes it easier to have money
that is outside of the state guns
3d printing of guns is an example of a
technology that is more of a rightward
shift but generally technology leads the
world left yeah it's it's also usually
highly educated people that are involved
in technology in the first place and I
think when you look at universities in
particular they tend to lean left in
this country as well well universities
what happened to the university is very
interesting universities first when you
know became the arbiters of data and
intellectualism and what's right and
wrong so the time period when it was
like should we be doing that or not well
let's look at the university what do
they have to say what are the smartest
people the professors that think tanks
have to say and the universities got
this credibility from the hard sciences
so they got this from
you know physics and math and computer
science and chemistry because these
deliver real things the Manhattan
Project the microprocessor the space
vehicles and so on the electric car so
they gained this mantle of authority and
legitimacy from the hard sciences so
then come the social sciences kind of
sneaked in then you get economy
economics and microeconomics is a real
discipline real science real math behind
it logic reason and then you get
macroeconomics which can be politicized
a little bit more voodoo and then you
get social studies and then you get
Gender Studies and then you get blah
blah blah blah blah blah and so what
happened is that because we took
scientists to be the high priests of our
new world science itself has gotten
corrupted and the social sciences and
you can tell they're fake sciences
because they're the word science tacked
on at the end have come in and hijacked
the universities and become the new
think tanks and so essentially what you
see going on today in the universities
is a war between the social sciences and
the physical sciences and the crossover
point is biology right where you can see
like the whole gender is a social
construct movement is attacking biology
and evolutionary biology just like in
the social sphere they're coming after
the comedians right but you can see the
struggle going on the universities and I
would say the physical sciences are
essentially losing that war what can be
done or is it just something that has to
play out is it do we have to realize the
consequences of the foolishness well the
good news of the physical sciences have
a reality on their side yeah but it's
not even I mean in many ways it's not
respected yeah but you at the end of the
day you're you're aircraft still has to
fly you know your microprocessor still
has to compute and so there's only so
far they can they can take it but I do
see for example in biology a lot of
biologists are facing this difficult
thing where they have to save things
that they know are not true to keep
their job like what oh you had Brett
Weinstein on here mm-hmm right so that's
that's a clear example so it there's
just the crossover line of what is
acceptable what's not is entering into a
biology and biology will probably suffer
the most synthetic biology for example
will you know a lot of this will end up
in China because it won't be you you
won't be able to map
in reality and actions together you
won't be able to get grants you won't be
able to get the adulation of your peers
I don't I don't know enough here so now
I'm in shaky territory but it's just my
sense that that crossover battleground
right now is in evolutionary biology
economics lost
well it's certainly in terms of gender
and that that sort of that seems to be
one of the major battlegrounds yeah it's
also gonna happen we have a blank slate
theory you know are we nature or we
nurture it's kind of socially
unacceptable to say that you know a lot
of it is nature and not nurture or vice
versa depending on which side you're on
right those kinds of discussions get
corrupted they do get corrupted and it's
really unfortunate because that's an
unbelievably important thing to
understand like what makes a person a
sociopath what makes a person a super
successful person a winner
what makes a person a drug addict what
would what are these factors you can't
have a reasonable conversation about
climate science anymore it's not a
science melting it aside you can't even
bring it up everyone's got their minds
made up already well it's what's
uncomfortable to me is people have their
minds made up and they don't even have
the data on most of these topics people
are talking past each other anyway
talking about different things like when
you get into you know when you when you
get into gun control for example right
one side is talking about the right to
bear arms in case a tyrannical ruler or
King drastic over the country the other
time the other side is talking about
school shootings and you know protecting
people in their homes right from crime
so they're just talking about two
different things right and it's just not
politically acceptable to even talk
about the same thing or when you get to
immigration the right is talking about
you know the other left is like bundling
together illegal immigration and legal
immigration into one thing yes right
where's in the on the right sometimes
you got racists hiding in there so it
doesn't help their cause right they're
talking about two different things yeah
if they were talking about the same
thing which is how many immigrants
should we let into the country and you
know what are the criteria for that that
would be a very different conversation
than no immigrants or everybody comes in
and then also on the Left you know you
have this benefit that everybody who's
currently coming in illegally is gonna
vote for the left because of
they're coming from in their
socio-economic circumstances hmm
to me the test of any good system is you
build a system hand it over to your
enemies to run for the next decade so
for example if you want a censorship on
Twitter or Facebook you should build
that system and then hand it over to the
other side to run so if you're a left
winger who's promoting censorship that's
somebody else running same with
immigration if you want immigration
system build the system then hand it
over to the other side to running
there's how you know it's a good system